while you might earn more money than you  would in some other careers because of  some of the challenges I mentioned  earlier in the video like demanding work  schedules and difficulty to achieve  work-life balance a lot of Consultants  tend to get burnt out and leave after  just a few years so here just to react  to that so on the salary side of course  she is right yes Consulting in general  is a good and rather high paying career  for many of them and then it's also no  secret that the MVB consulting firms are  one of the firms that pay the highest  salaries right so you can expect  yourself being even at the higher end of  all the Spectrum so yes of course the  salaries are high but what you also  rightfully explains is that the demands  are higher on you as well so you will  have a less well work life balance there  will be quite a significant amount of  stress and pressure on you